let's see if we can simplify this
expression and like always pause the
video and have a go at it
now this one is interesting because it
involves two variables but it's really
the same ideas that we've done when we
factored things with one variable so for
example up here in the numerator well I
never like having a non-one coefficient
on the second degree term here I mean
sometimes you have to but for it looks
like every term here is divisible by
five so let's factor out a 5 first
so the numerator I can rewrite as 5
times 5 times you factor out a 5 here
you get x squared factor out of 5 here
you get plus 4 actually I'm going to
rewrite it as 4y X and you'll see in a
second and why I'm doing that actually
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why I'm
doing that right now why I'm writing the
Y there is that this way it seems to it
seems to hit your the pattern of how
we're used to seeing quadratics so let's
see so you have x squared plus 4y X you
can view the 4y is the coefficient on
the first degree in X term on the X term
right over there plus 4y squared and
it's going to be over over now the
denominator here can we factor this out
well let's just think about it do we
know to two numbers or I guess so you
say do we know two expressions that
would add that when you multiply them
you get negative 6y squared and then
when you add them you get negative x y
so or sorry when you add them you get
negative y that's actually why I liked
writing it like this so actually let me
rewrite this this is the same thing as
negative Y X and so you can view the
coefficient here as negative Y and so we
need to think of two numbers so or two
expressions a times B that is equal to
negative 6y squared and when I add them
a plus B I get that is equal to negative
Y and so you can imagine both of them
are going to be expressions a and B are
going to be expressions that involve Y
and so let's see if you if this was just
a negative one and if the
just a negative six what we would do we
would do negative three and positive two
and let's see if we did negative 3y and
positive 2y that indeed is going to be
equal to negative 6y squared and
negative 3y plus 2i does indeed equal
negative Y so that's our a and B right
over there and if it seems a little
mysterious how did Sal just all of a
sudden get negative 2y or negative 3y
and positive 2y let me write a analogous
quadratic here that only has one
variable if I were to write x squared
minus X minus 6 and I were to ask you to
factor that out you say okay well this
is going I have negative 2 I have
negative 3 times negative 2 is negative
6 and if I add them well that's going to
be negative 1 so you would say well
that's going to be that's going to be X
minus 3 times X plus 2 and so the only
difference between this and that is
instead of having just a negative 1 here
you have a negative 1y instead of having
just a negative 6 here you have a
negative 6y squared and so you could
just think of this instead of just
negative 3 and positive 2 negative 3y
and positive 2y hopefully that makes
sense and if it doesn't I encourage you
to to kind of play around with this
multiply these out a little bit a little
bit of more more familiar with this but
once we now that we know that can be
factored like this let's rewrite this
this is going to be X minus 3y times X
plus 2y and nothing seems to simplify
out just yet but it looks like what we
have in magenta here could be simplified
further and we're going to a very
similar exercise to what we did just now
what two expressions if I multiply them
I get 4y squared and if I add them I get
4y looks like 2y would do the trick so
it seems like we can rewrite the
numerator this is going to be so let me
draw a little line here to make it clear
that this is this is going to be equal
to five times
X plus 2y times I could say just x plus
2y squared or I can just say X plus 2y
times X plus 2y once again 2y times 2 is
4 y squared - y plus 2y is 4y and so and
that's all going to be over that is all
going to be over X minus 3y x minus 3y
times X plus 2i and so now I have a
common factor X plus 2y in both the
numerator and the denominator so I can
Candle x plus 2y divided by X plus 2i
well that's just going to be 1 if we
assume that X plus 2y does not equal 0
and that's actually an important
constraint because once we cancel this
out you lose that information if you
want this to be algebraically equivalent
we could say that X plus 2i cannot be
equal to 0 or another way you could say
it is that X cannot be equal to cannot
be equal to negative 2y I just
subtracted 2y from both sides there and
so what you're left with and we can
redistribute this five if we want to
write it out in an expanded form we
could rewrite it as the numerator would
be 5x let me write it over here 5x + 10
y and the denominator is X minus 3y but
once again if we want them to be
algebraically equivalent we would have
to say X cannot be equal to X cannot be
equal to negative 2y and now this is
algebraically equivalent to what we had
up here and you can argue that it's a
little bit simpler